- Night owls like myself, we're just
full of vodka and like
nachos or something.
(upbeat string music)
(wolf howling)
- I usually go to bed maybe
around one every night.
- Between like 12 and two.
- Anywhere between 12 and 3am.
- I wake up for work as
late as I possibly can
to still get there on
time and in one piece.
- I hit snooze five or six times
before getting up in the morning.
- I desperately want
to be a morning person.
- I love the idea of people getting up,
like walking their dogs,
and like being healthy,
and eating granola and yogurt.
- I could be a much more productive person
if I utilized those morning hours.
- I'm about to wake up early as (bleep),
and I'm really excited but nervous
that I won't be able to do it.
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] Hey, Kelsey.
- Hey, what's up?
- I do. I get up around 3:30 every day.
- I power lift and I prefer to train
in the morning as opposed to the evening.
Honestly, it's a better, like
more healthy way of living.
I have more time in the day.
I can get more stuff done.
I'm not as rushed, and honestly
our ancestors lived that way.
They woke up with the sun
and went to bed with the sun,
so for me, it's the more
natural way of living.
- Yeah, I would love to help
some night owls wake up early.
Rule number one is--
- No!
- Oh!
(laughs)
- Monday through Friday, you need
to be up by 5am.
Saturday and Sunday, I would prefer
if you were up by eight o'clock.
Rule number two, with your extra time
in the morning, do something that you
love to do, that you don't normally
have time to do.
- Like walking my dog.
- Cook a serious breakfast maybe.
Number three is, this is Sunday night
through Thursday night, you need
to be in bed between nine and 11.
Friday and Saturday night, 10pm to 1am,
because I know people like to go out.
- I'm gonna have no life!
Nothing gets started until ten.
- Ok. Let's get into it!
- Let's do it, guys!
- I think you guys can do it.
I think you'll surprise yourself
in another two weeks.
- Let's go! Whoo!
- Whoo!
- I'm going to bed way
later than I wanted to,
but the night just kind
of got away from me.
- My goal is to wake up tomorrow
and work out before work.
I'm optimistic. I'm excited.
I hope that I can do this.
- I failed my first night.
Today we'll do better though.
I'm like a mess in the morning, holy shit!
- Actually I don't feel that tired.
Upon a very short conversation
with my boyfriend,
I realized I'm in a
really bad mood! (laughs)
I am just incapable of communicating
properly with other humans.
- I had time for a little
bit of stretching and yoga,
and I'm also gonna have
time to do my hair.
(car alarm blaring)
- It's 10am on a Saturday.
Much too early for me,
so we headed to Starbucks
for some much-needed caffeine
and I'm so cranky about it!
- So, I'm at work. Sleepy as fuck.
Basically, I've been
failing, as of lately.
Well, no.
The weekend I woke up really early.
- So, we're supposed to get up super early
for our breakfast tomorrow,
but I'm exhausted.
We'll see how it goes.
I mean, I have to do it.
It will be the worst thing ever
if I somehow don't make it.
- I am absolutely miserable.
- You're such a drama queen.
- No one is up this early!
- Look, there are plenty of people out.
- There are four people here.
- I'm actually doing chores
before the sun's out!
What!
- I just realized that the new episode
of Scream Queens is on Hulu,
so I'm actually gonna try to catch
a little bit of it, pour
myself a tiny glass of wine,
even though the rules say I shouldn't.
I wanted to be just like
my friends on Instagram,
and I failed miserably.
- I have been getting up earlier,
so in the mornings I'm more relaxed.
It's a better start to the day,
and I just feel like I'm in a better mood.
- The first week I definitely noticed
that my body would be up, but my brain
wouldn't be up with me at the same time.
Waking up and doing something physical
and centering, like
yoga, definitely helped
me get both of my halves
started with the day.
- I enjoy my night life so much,
and the fact that conversations
would just be getting good at like 11
and I was already late to bed
was kind of a weird thing.
- I definitely think
that people who consider
themselves night owls should
try waking up earlier.
Maybe even just by like an hour or so.
It feels really good to not
be rushed in the morning.
- I'd really like to make
this like a legit life change.
Where I actually become
a real morning person.
- Ugh. Goodbye night life.
It's been nice knowing you.
I'm gonna start hanging out
with morning moms now.
(upbeat music)